let's go next to Thomas from Canada
Thomas from Canada what's going on today
we've heard from Thomas before hi hi
David is this my my online you're on
you're on right now literally okay great
so I I called again because I was
wondering I don't know what you thought
and I've noticed that you've brought
this up and I say this respectfully
because I I really do enjoy your show
please this notion of the American Dream
so from a Canadian perspective it seems
bizarre oh do you know what I mean no I
don't tell me
so encounter well we don't have an
equivalent to the Canadian dream not
really we do and we don't and we also
don't like so while we are I think a
proud people we also don't and I've also
noticed you and I say this respectfully
you know talk about this notion of what
our founding fathers thought well in
Canada we don't say well you know our
founding fathers the founding members
are kind of thought this we look at them
at like we look at them as as people who
died about a century ago and this gives
us some good material so yes
number one Canada seems to have a much
healthier and realistic relationship
with the founders and the documents that
the founders put together rather than as
almost quasi religious documents but
more just as like this is the best thing
certain people who were flawed came up
with at the time based on what they knew
then and things have changed the world
has changed we need to take that into a
consideration so it you it seems that
there's a much healthier relationship
there in general than we have in the US
with so-called constitutional fetishists
would you my questions would you agree
that there's almost a nice and I say
this out of respect to you know cuz I
because you you come off as an academic
would be someone who knows what he's
talking about I and I respect that
compared to some other channels and I
and I wonder like why is there almost a
prosumer inch on this notion that or our
founding fathers was against who cares
that your founding by no no how about
that better yet is it relevant
2090 if your founding fathers were
racist who cares they're they've been
dead for two centuries right isn't it so
much more now I worry these are talking
points that say Democrats Republicans
and God knows everyone else in the
middle and left and right
hey well yeah no you're completely right
believe thanks for talking points that
are meant to defend a particular
political view and conservatism in
general wants to keep things the way
they were for the sake of keeping them
the way they were I mean these are
course generalizations but the idea of
progress is to change things for the
better based on what we know now and
learning from the lessons of history
conservatism wants to keep things the
way they were in some kind of nostalgic
previous period and so the
constitutional fetishism serves a
particular political ideology and in the
same way by the way Thomas you mentioned
the American dream at the beginning of
the show the idea of the of the American
dream at the beginning of the call the
idea of the American dream also supports
a particular set of ideas and actions
which prop up industry and the status
quo the American Dream which includes
for example home ownership and having
two cars even if you can't afford them
which funds big corporations and
interest-bearing loan you know you you
so it all has to be interpreted in that
context I think well my question I've
even noticed it on The Young Turks right
and I think there and and even other
channels David
cedar I believe that I in my mind
questions why is it like the American
Dream is obviously a falsehood obviously
I mean it's there to support
capitalistic socio-economic ideas why I
mean I don't know it's it's if we all
could become millionaires then there'd
be no meaning and being a millionaire
any longer I mean logically so if
everyone was given the same amount of
money today well then we'd have a new
system then sir you know it's a very
like from a Canadian perspective I say
this out of respect when I hear this
notion the founding fathers constantly
brought up to with gun laws for instance
yes it's it's bizarre from a Canadian
perspective and I said it's respectfully
so it is a bizarre weird notion to say
well
yes two centuries ago what that I can't
imagine they thought ak-47s would be a
thing one day maybe with you Thomas
absolutely a point well made and one
I've made in the past a pleasure to hear
from you and I'm gonna try to get to
some other callers okay a pleasure a
pleasure to talk to you again everybody
Thomas from Canada Thomas from Canada